- I could say the
performance is the moment
when the performer with his own idea
step in his own mental
physical construction
in the front of the
audience in particular time.
This is not a theater.
A theater will repeat.
Theater replace somebody else.
Theater isn't like box.
Performance is real.
In a theater you can cut with a knife
and there is blood.
The knife is not real
and blood is not real.
In performance the blood
and the knife and the body
of the performer is real.
It's very hard to make a strong,
illuminating, you know, work of art.
I'm more interested idea
I really fear about.
I'm really interested in
idea who change something or,
you know, make me learn something.
If you do things you like
or you have the pleasure,
you know, doing it, you'll never change.
You're always in the same
pattern and everything
is happening the same way
again and again in your life.
Performance is the kind
of unique form of art
and is very temporary and comes and goes.
And in every society it's
different relation to performance.
In the 70's it was body art
and then disappear completely.
In the 80's because the
market was all focused
on goods and something to sell,
there was nothing to sell
with the performance.
It was just memory.
Every time the economical
crisis in the world
the performers become kind of evident.
I don't expect anything for myself
is this expectation to be there 100%.
I expect to be absolutely,
whatever I do, 100%.
And it is up to audience
how they take it or not.
And I will be-- I like them to be present,
because the work is done for the audience.
Without the audience
the world doesn't exist.
It doesn't make any meaning.